good morning my name is marion zuffle
and i work for the new york state
integrated pest management program
today i'm going to talk to you about
insect pests or potential insect pests
of hemp
and their management this was my first
summer working in hemp and i've really
enjoyed the experience
so my goal this summer was to just go
out there
and learn as much as i can about hemp
try to identify any insects
and diseases that are out there so today
i'm going to specifically just talk
about the insect pests we've already
heard about some of the diseases out
there
so i'm just going to focus in on what
insects i found
before i get started i first just wanted
to stress the importance of scouting and
identification because not everything
that's out there is a pest
in fact very few insects to date have
caused enough damage to impact hemp
and this crop is still relatively new so
we don't have a lot of thresholds for
any insect pests that we do find
so for this reason it's very important
for you to go out scout your hem fields
regularly and that way you can notice
any potential problems and keep an eye
on them
so what i did this summer was i scouted
nine different hem fields
weekly as well as one high tunnel and i
also set up
european corn borer tracks which you can
see here in the picture
next to hempfield so i can monitor the
flight of european corn borer which is
one of the known pests
potential pests of hemp again not
everything is a pest so we have to be
able to identify
what's a pest what's a beneficial and
what's an incidental an insect
that just happens to be out in the field
but isn't causing any damage
okay so now i'm going to go over some of
the insects that i did find this season
the first one that i encountered was
early in the season while the plants
were still in the greenhouse
the grower came to me and he informed me
that hundreds of the seedlings were
dying
and you can see that from the top upper
right hand corner
the seedlings were turning yellow and
were dying and he wasn't quite sure what
was causing it
and we noticed that he had a lot of
fungus gnats and he also had fusarium
and we determined that it was fucerum we
took some seedlings and sent them to
chris smart and she identified fusarium
in the seedlings
so the fungus gnats they are tiny little
flies that lay their eggs
in wet soil near the base of the plants
the larvae will
hatch out of the eggs and then they
start feeding on decaying matter but
they will also feed on roots
and both the adult fungus gnats as well
as the larvae can transmit diseases such
as fusarium
so what the grower did is he changed out
his potting media and then he also
decreased his watering he was
over watering his plants and you're
supposed to really let them dry out
between waterings let the top layer dry
out between waterings
and that really helped his um fungus net
problem
and he also introduced nematodes so one
thing you can do to monitor for fungus
gnats is you can place yellow sticky
cards in your greenhouse
so that you can detect them early if you
do have fungus gnats
you should allow this top layer of soil
to dry out completely this will
kill both the fungus as well as which
the nets feed on as well as the
fungusnet larvae so really let that soil
dry out between waterings
this is the two spotted spider mite
these are small little mites found on
the underside of leaves and they cause
this stippling appearance that you can
see in both of the pictures kind of on
the upper surface of the leaves you
usually notice the stippling first and
then if you turn the leaf over you'll
find the
spider mites these i found in the high
tunnel as well as in the field
and both of them both in the high tunnel
as well as in the field the numbers
stayed fairly low the high tunnel has
since been harvested
and no control measures were needed and
the populations in the field have never
increased i monitor it weekly and the
numbers have stayed very very low
two spotted spider mites do prefer very
hot dry weather
so one of the ways to manage for them is
to make sure that your plants aren't
water stressed
you can also remove any potential weed
hosts that are surrounding your field
and then if you do have a spider mite
problem or you know that you will
you can release predatory mites to
control the spread of my population
but if you do do this you have to do it
in advance of
the spider mites becoming out of control
so as soon as you have that first sign
of two spotted spider mites you want to
release your beneficial predatory mites
this is the red-headed flea beetle which
was probably the most numerous insect
that i observed this summer
the adults are fairly large three to six
millimeters and have a reddish brown
head and a shiny black body
they feed on the leaves between the
between the veins and
cause these holes all over the leaves
even though they were very numerous
and i saw quite a bit of damage all the
plants grew out of it
and the young seedlings are the ones
that are most at risk from flea beetle
damage
so some of the control measures you can
do is you can protect your young
seedlings with row cover until they're
large enough to withstand the feeding
pressure
you can also plow in the to decrease the
overwintering population
and then you can use beneficial
nematodes which will control the larvae
in the soil
i also found some aphids these are small
sap sucking insects kind of pear-shaped
they're found on the underside of the
leaves but they can also be found near
the stem
or in the flowers there are several
different species
of aphids that are known to occur on
hemp of the nine fields that i was
scouting
only one of them did i find aphids in
and
they remained on the lower leaves and
there was a lot of beneficials including
ladybugs and my new pirate bugs
and lace wings that really kept the
population under control
they are still out there and i'm still
monitoring them weekly
to make sure that the population doesn't
get any bigger
i did take a sample and i sent it to the
cornell insect diagnostic lab
for identification because i don't know
what species it is
but i only found the one in one field
there are a few different insects that
will bore into the stem of hemp
including the common stock bore which is
pictured here as well as european corn
borer and the hemp ore the only one that
i found this
season was the common stock board i've
not found the other ones
i did set up traps for european corn
borer but the numbers were very very low
and i never found any in the plant
so here's a picture of a larvae inside a
hemp stock
they are brown with these long white
lines that run the length of the body
the female will lay her eggs in grasses
and weeds kind of around
the edge of a field and when they hatch
the when the larvae hatch
they will move into the field looking
for a suitable plant to bore into
so one of the management options is to
control your weeds and grasses
in the surrounding fields usually if you
do have stock bore
it's going to be on the edge of fields
where you're going to find the damage
another option is to plant your plants
early so that they're large enough that
when
the larvae move in they can withstand
some of that boring damage
chemical control options are limited
because once they're inside the stem
they're protected from any kind of
chemical control
this is the last insect that i'm going
to talk about the yellow woolly bear
caterpillar
this is a caterpillar that feeds on many
different plants including hemp
it's covered in yet dense yellow hairs
over its entire body
and this one i found in the high tunnel
that i was scouting and usually it
doesn't cause a problem the female lays
about 50 eggs on a host plant
and the caterpillars they feed together
for a little while but then they
disperse throughout the field
and just cause a little bit of damage to
individual plants
but because this was in a high tunnel
they were all concentrated in one
area and they couldn't disperse it
caused much more significant damage
so when i was in their scouting i
noticed a lot of the plants the lower
third
of the plant was completely defoliated
so i notified the grower about that
and what we ended up doing he just went
in and hand-picked them all
there's probably about a hundred or so
in the high tunnel but he could control
them since it wasn't a defined area he
could just go in
and hand pick them off to remove them
and it didn't really cause any
serious damage because we were able to
get rid of them
so here just real briefly is a list of
some of the other insects that i found
on him which includes the leaf miner
which i'm attempting to rear out to
determine what kind of
what species it is four line plant bug
various caterpillars
different grasshoppers brown marmorated
stink bug
leaf hoppers tree hoppers um the oblique
banded leaf roller i was able to rear
that out
um and the tarnished plant bug so as you
can see there's a lot of different
insects that are found on hemp
not all of them are pests so it's
important to know what's a pest which
just what's
an incidental and of course as i
mentioned before what are your
beneficials so that you can
just control the ones that you need to
so if there's any questions
i will take those now